so mancher lebt im überfluss und sperrt
sich einen wird bald mehr als
überflüssig seien
warum schützt sich mit privatarmeen sie
haben aufgehört zu fühlen und zu sehen
er sinkt weil er ein lied hat er dichtet
weil er nicht anders kann
und weil er nicht müde geworden ist vom
aufwecken
ich glaube dass es ein überleben der
menschheit irgendwann nur noch geben
kann wenn es eine gewaltfreie menschheit
werden wird wir sind das einzige
geschöpft dieser erde das in der lage
ist die erde zu vernichten
es muss eine revolution der vernunft
sein es muss eine revolution des
verstandes der geistlichkeit des
bewusstseins sein
wehrt euch beschwert euch entrüstet euch
kämpferisch fordert wecker auf zu
frieden und gerechtigkeit sein ganzes
leben so scheint es hat er den
widerstand verschrieben
ich glaube das hat zu tun mit meinem
elternhaus
meine eltern waren keine nazis und wir
konnten reden über diese zeit und mein
vater hat den kriegsdienst verweigert in
der nazizeit
wie durch ein wunder überlebt und durch
diese haltung die da in unserer familie
war war es eigentlich
es ist bis heute klar dass ich irgendwo
dem andenken meines vaters auch treu
bleiben möchte
es herrscht wieder frieden im land seit
40 jahren schmettert er seine lieder in
die welt zornig inbrünstig ohne angst
vor pathos
seine balladen hymnen ihrer zeit ein
wilder ein lautstarker künstler rockstar
der intellektuell
immer mitten im prallen leben auf
rauschhaften höhenflügen aber auch mit
abstürzen in drogenexzesse schulden und
knast ich habe sehr viel blödsinn
gemacht
einiges davon ist auch öffentlich
geworden aber ich habe immer versucht in
meinen gedichten etwas sprechen zu
lassen was was aus mir raus bricht also
ich hab da was dran gebastelt ich habe
nie ich kann das auch gar nicht ich kann
ich muss bei jedem gedicht muss ich
eigentlich warten bis es mir passiert
die muse geküsst waren sie will der ewig
ungehorsame träumt von einer zärtlichen
revolution unbeirrbar auch wenn manch
einer belächelt den weltverbesserer den
archiven
ich bin richtig darf anif sein und ich
darf bis sein
ich muss sogar du bist sein und ich sage
auch ich bin in erster linie dazu da um
die stimme des pazifismus nicht
aussterben zu lassen
ja das sehe ich als meine funktion an
als als als als projekt
die kinder werden unsere seien keine
hautfarbe und kein song keine menschen
fahrende ideologie trennt uns von diesem
raum wenn politisieren bedeutet für mich
eben auch dass man symbole symbole sein
lässt und nicht versucht alles
auszudeuten und alles ausgedeutet wird
dann wieder zu einem machtmittel die
politisierung der welt dichtung und
gesang die waffen des anarchisten und
rebellen das interessante ist dass ich
oft in meinem leben rebellisch war und
gar nicht gedacht habe dass seine
wellisch sondern auch zu ist man halt
das ist es muss so sein haben wir die
anderen an dem kunden als rebellisch
wenn die so singen
dann fliegt vor einem geheimen war das
ganze verkehrt gewesen